[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show we have
learned that Ginny Thomas the wife of
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
will be speaking with the house January
6 committee NPR is now reporting it and
saying that an agreement has been
reached the plan will be to interview
Thomas after the plan to interview
Thomas rather was announced right after
the committee confirmed it's going to
hold a public hearing on Wednesday
September 28th oh that's sort of another
live stream I should look at doing I'll
make a note of that on the calendar
right now so j6 hearing hopefully it'll
be like an evening one although I'm did
they say whether they're going to be
prime time from here on out
well that's on Wednesday so yeah it's
hard to glean weather that would be
during the day or prime time I don't
know at this point but it sounds like
you're going to have live streams just
about every single day this week yeah
it's going to be insane oh no you know
what it's it's gonna be at 1pm on
Wednesday that's going to be tight
that's going to be very very tight for
me doable though possibly doable I'll
have to see what I actually have going
on that day so it's believed that Ginny
Thomas will be testifying uh behind
closed doors as the term may be
um which is of course not ideal for us
but they continue to say this is
voluntary her attorney says this is
voluntary it's all completely and
totally voluntary now why do we care
about Ginny Thomas we care about Jenny
Thomas because we have since the Trump
the Trump Riots of January 6th found out
about her connections to those seeking
to send these alternate slates of
electoral uh of electors in certain
States uh it's relevant because of her
association with groups seeking to
overturn the election results while
being married to a Supreme Court Justice
whose Court did to a small degree and
could have had much more uh judicial
work related to that very
um attempt to overturn the legend and
she's just it stinks to high heaven is
the term I keep going back to
yep and just because the testimony is
going to be behind closed doors that
doesn't mean that we won't necessarily
get glimpses of it because remember the
Trump kids also testified behind closed
doors so to speak and we got little
clips of those interwoven in the
presentation that we got from members of
the panel yeah so this could happen in
the exact same way it's not like she's
going to be out in front of everyone in
that room testifying but like maybe
we'll get a few things she wants to go
on the record about and then we'll hear
about it later and uh it also makes
sense that she would want to just comply
I think with the questions because if
she decides not to answer to the request
maybe she would get subpoenaed maybe she
would get charged with contempt of
congress like other people have been uh
wrapped up and then this investigation
so far and given the fact that she's an
attorney herself who's married to a
Supreme Court Justice that would just be
a really bad look so considering all of
her options this is probably the best
way to go for her I think she is so
obviously a political hack and and
everything is so inappropriate in terms
of her involvement and Clarence Thomas
not recusing himself like without a
doubt I have no qualms saying any of
that
I think this is all going nowhere in
terms of both Ginny Thomas and Clarence
Thomas what do you think
I think it's going nowhere also it is
unfortunate because you know just
because Ginny Thomas is married to
Clarence Thomas that shouldn't exclude
her necessarily from being able to be a
political actor sure obviously it's not
going to exclude her from having her own
political views but then you still you
get to this conflict of interest because
she's still married after also a Supreme
Court Judge who's supposed to be
apolitical so like it's all like we're
pretending here
um that maybe she's not corrupted or
corrupting Clarence Thomas or any of
these things how do you draw the line
with those sort of things it's difficult
it is when a case like this comes up to
the Supreme Court it's obvious that
Clarence Thomas should have to recuse
himself but then if he decides not to
there's really not too much recourse to
that either so it's all very very tricky
and that's the protect Perpetual issue
we are having with this chord which is
that it is the most activist Court I can
remember and there's essentially no
recourse and I know people talk about
well you can impeach these justices but
I mean there's no real realistic chance
of that happening oh no I mean if you
can't realistically impeach a president
you're probably not going to be able to
do it for Supreme Court Justice yeah as
well so there's really no hope of that
but um yeah it is unfortunate that we're
in this situation now and that the
extremists have taken over hey I don't
know how many people remember this story
but there was this viral story of a
white woman who falsely told police she
was being threatened by a black guy who
was bird watching in New York City's
Central Park the video went viral it was
all Bonkers this is Amy Cooper and Amy
Cooper was ultimately fired by Franklin
Templeton because they decided hey it's
just not good for us to be associated
with this woman uh she then sued saying
that she was fired illegally and
portrayed as a racist by her former
employee Franklin Templeton and we now
have a decision from that case U.S
District Judge Ronnie Abrams rejected
the claim and said Franklin Templeton
did not defame you chief executive Jenny
Johnson
said that they don't tolerate racism and
that's why you were fired and that is
not defamatory and that's it and
basically saying you have not failed to
prove you were fired because you were
white or because you are a woman and
this is I mean it
subtle or not because on the one hand
she was fired because her racist action
went viral now you could say were she
black the same action may not have been
construed as racist even if it was the
same action so in a sense her race is a
factor in why we find it racist if a
black woman called the police on a black
man we might not feel as though it was
racist in the same way but to say that
it's because of her race also doesn't
really make sense
well that's the thing like you can never
definitively prove these things when
Cooper called the police she did say
there's an African-American man
threatening my life and it doesn't
necessarily mean that she views him as a
threat simply because he's black maybe
she's just trying to identify describing
yeah so it is difficult but I think that
you can just use your human judgment and
you watch the video and you think okay
well there does seem to be some racist
aspect to it and also I think it's
important to point out that the company
didn't call her a racist per se they
just said that they don't tolerate
racism so maybe they consider that this
one instance that that came from her was
racist doesn't necessarily mean
someone's racist overall I mean maybe
someone makes an off-color joke or you
know has a racist thought here and there
obviously it points the direction of
them having racist views overall but it
doesn't mean that they're full on a
racist necessarily so I think that also
plays a role in this too and a
defamation case for something like this
that's going to be hard too she's not
really a public figure but the case
already blew up to a point where I don't
think that her getting fired from this
fired over this from her job would
really stand up couple other things on
this it just so happens that this
incident in Central Park took place on
the same day that George Floyd was
killed in Minneapolis just uh
I don't know that we learned about it on
the same day necessarily but it took
place on that same day the other thing
is remember the truth of the incident
the truth of the incident is the black
guy asked the white woman to leash her
dog and dogs are supposed to be leashed
in Central Park
she then called the police and said
there's an African-American man
threatening my life and recall that in
the viral video while she was on the
phone with the police she was almost
like strangling her dog with the leash I
mean every aspect of the story was nuts
yeah that actually also suggests that
there was a racist component to it the
fact that there was no evidence that the
man was threatening her life in any way
he asked her to leash the dog like the
fact that she jumped to that conclusion
that to me suggests there was a racial
component here 100 and so we will see
what is next for now you know whenever
someone gets fired for something like
this
sometimes right-wingers who selectively
defend speech and sometimes don't we'll
come out and say you're trying to take
away her livelihood you're saying she
are you saying she should never work
again it's like no what we're saying is
if you defend
corporate rights to make the decisions
that you deem right for your business
without government interference and the
decision wasn't illegal right they
didn't say you're fired because you're
white they didn't say you're fired
because you're a woman she wasn't able
to even demonstrate that that was
implicit in the firing
what we're saying is the company must be
allowed to make this Human Resources
decision she can then go and get a job
anywhere else that will hire her but
understand the alternative would be
either telling the company you're not
allowed to fire her because she did
something embarrassing
or you have to tell other companies they
must hire her all of those are very
heavy-handed government intervention so
it's like what it's very easy to say are
you saying she should never work again
no she should have the opportunity to
participate in the job market that
everybody has and sometimes you have
disadvantages because of where you live
or different things she has a
disadvantage because she did this
horrible thing that went viral but what
alternative is there right exactly you
described it perfectly it's not an ideal
situation I too don't think that she
should be barred from ever being able to
work again and of course hopefully she's
able to find employment but it's going
to be up to the specific company that
decides to hire her or not they know
that there's going to be a public
relations angle to this and the
alternative is to say that you have to
hire this person which we obviously
can't have but the right that's so
willing to defend her maybe they'll be
willing to hire her like she can end up
working at the daily wire or maybe on
infowar or something like that we've
seen that sort of thing sure yeah I
don't know if she's a good candidate for
broadcast journalism necessarily but
hey it's the free market of of
employment and that's certainly
something that she could pursue I guess
it doesn't take too much skill to do
that on the right you just have to be
able to complain and act um outraged all
the time yeah which she can do it we
know she can do that so listen I've said
before I love the FIFA World Cup I love
soccer I love watching the Argentinian
Men's National Team I'm really excited
for the World Cup coming up uh I believe
Argentina's first game is November 22nd
I love all of it okay not no no qualms
there but FIFA is a very corrupt
organization and this year in particular
the World Cup is taking place in Qatar
not exactly a place with the best record
on human rights with stadiums in Qatar
reportedly built by what is essentially
slave labor uh indentured servitude
people whose passports are sometimes
held etc etc
we now have a new controversy involving
the World Cup
FIFA has come under pressure from some
of the European soccer federations
because the European soccer federations
want the captains of their teams to wear
an armband with a rainbow heart design
and it's part of a campaign against
discrimination
and FIFA rules prohibit teams from
bringing their own armband designs to
the World Cup and say you have to use
what's provided by FIFA and the armbands
are
players with a political message
connected to the fact that Qatar is the
place that the World Cup is being hosted
it's illegal to engage in a gay act in
Qatar the treatment of the migrant
workers as the Associated Press reports
for the building of the stadiums has
been a controversy since we first
reported that the World Cup would be in
Qatar about a decade ago and so the idea
here is send a message send a political
message and it is now going to be a
question about what is going to be
allowed the Associated Press reports
that FIFA supported taking a knee if
players want
and now has to decide whether they are
going to back this armband thing all of
which could potentially be embarrassing
to Qatar so my thoughts on this are
twofold
There are rules that people agree to
which is FIFA has to agree to this stuff
am I suggesting that the teams ignore
that and risk getting kicked out no I'm
not suggesting that but I completely
support
any activist campaigns to publicly shame
Qatar
for a very long list of things and that
that's sort of where I come down on yeah
and some people would go a lot farther
and they'd say well all these players
all these teams should just boycott
playing in Qatar I think we're probably
beyond that point because there's been
so much build up to this and I think if
there was going to be pressure on FIFA
to pick a different location it would
have worked by now and these players
maybe they only get to play in a handful
of World Cups and so they may not want
to skip out on one they want to deliver
for their control is a lot I mean
they're every four years and if you're
in the prime of your career yeah you're
not going to want to pass up on this
this actually would be effective though
it's like the next best thing in a way
yeah because what are they going to do
realistically if all of the European
teams are doing this if you have some of
the best players in the world
participating in this protest are they
going to say the kick out every team
they're not gonna be able to kick out
every team they're not going to be able
to kick out all the best players and so
I think this is a good way to
potentially embarrass Qatar and if
you're being really optimistic it could
get them to change their laws I looked
into it and they don't enforce the law
against homosexuality as much as other
countries in the region do so they're
not entirely as strict as some of these
other countries like Saudi Arabia for
example Iran but just the fact that they
have that law on the books and that
every now and then there's a case where
someone is detained over this
um that that's enough they should be
willing to do away with this and that
seems like a fair exchange for being
able to host the World Cup I completely
agree I hope to both see a lot of the
protesting
and I look forward to watching the
soccer I don't know who else is going to
be watching but from what I'm looking at
the latest World Cup odds Brazil is the
favorite with France and England
slightly behind
Spain slightly behind them and then
Germany and Argentina slightly behind
them uh depending on where you look
different teams are favored but I will
be rooting for Argentina I'm gonna get
my my uh my jersey out good I'm gonna
get an Argentina onesie for the baby
it's gonna be a whole thing but we will
also be protesting that it's in Qatar
are you willing to go on record and say
that this is Leo Messi's last chance to
it's got to gather a victory for
Argentina I think I've come to that
realization yeah he is how old is he now
he's 35 he'd be 39.
is it impossible is 39 impossible I
don't know it's not impossible but the
chances would be slim there's 10 chances
are slim yeah all right so if you're
going to be watching let us know if
you're boycotting let us know I will be
watching and protesting is my plan
um and we will we will take it from
there remember the finance channel is
Live be one of the first 5 000
subscribers still time to get in it's
free I mean it doesn't really matter
what does it mean to be one of the first
five thousand but it just sounds cool be
one of the first 5 000 subscribers on
the finance Channel and we'll be back
tomorrow show bonus show many different
things happen